let's go to the u.s southern border
where more than 19 thousand
unaccompanied migrant children are in
u.s
custody although the bidet
administration says it is moving
hundreds a day
out of border patrol stations and tent
facilities manuel buharquez went to
central america where
most of those migrants are coming from
adults and children alike fleeing those
poor countries
heading to the u.s border and this
morning manuel is in guatemala city
after talking to some people who are
considering
making that journey themselves manuel
good morning to you
good morning the biden administration is
making a push here to tell people that
the u.s border is not open and that they
should not
leave but the dire circumstances some
are facing
far outweigh any official demand and
smugglers are readily available to try
to profit
off their desperation
as we traveled through the guatemalan
state of altavera pass we couldn't help
but notice signs
appearing to advertise smuggler services
on the side of the road
trip to the usa financing available
so we're about to call the number that
was written on that sign to try to find
out what exactly they're offering and
how much it costs
0 1. she confirmed
it was the right number when she asked
who i was my nombre es manuel
soy pero is cbs news
nope no answer but people say it can
cost tens of thousands of dollars
often borrowed 19 year old francisco
cook made it all the way to mexico city
before he ran out of money to pay
smugglers
what do you think he'll
[Music]
that's because like many here in the
town of campur poverty has been worsened
by back-to-back hurricanes
it's not just kampur many remote farming
communities
like this one have suffered the same
fate the scars from the storms
still visible the crops they rely on
destroyed
the man who owned this home told me he's
run out of options and is considering
leaving
for the u.s but the u.s government has
put out radio messages warning people
not to come
so you've heard those ads
i asked him what he would tell vice
president kamala harris who has been
tasked with addressing the immigration
crisis
you want her to come here
he wishes the biden administration would
offer temporary work visas to
guatemalans who need them and in the
meantime says he has been urging people
not to go because of the dangers of the
journey not only to adults
but sadly to children and we are seeing
yet another disturbing example of that
along the u.s mexico border
take a look at video released by border
patrol showing an
agent coming across a crying boy near
the rio grande he is 10 years old
and says he's been abandoned by
smugglers and you can hear in his voice
just how scared
he is afraid he said of being kidnapped
or robbed
he is now in government custody like
thousands of
others officials say that he is from
nicaragua and is yet another example of
the dangers of human smuggling and the
desperation of families who are willing
to put their child
in the hands of strangers gail no manny
i saw that little boy this morning he
still got his baby teeth at 10 you were
still
so young do we know what's going to
happen to him i also heard that he has
relatives here
the fear in that little boy
oftentimes they do have relatives
they're trying to reach as for the boy
we haven't learned any additional
information from border patrol but as
you know he will be processed
and if there is someone in this country
in the united states i should say
that can take him in uh eventually the
government's goal would be to reunite
them
as you know it speaks to the desperation
thank you again manny i just love
watching your reports the way you
translate
on both sides so that everybody can
understand is really really masterful
thank you so much
thank you we'll see you again